peace be with you welcome to the DS show
we're here sharing because we care and
we're trying to inform you the sincere
viewer who wants to know about Islam you
want to know about your neighbor who's
possibly a Muslim or maybe opening up
some Islamic Center what are they going
to be doing in there are they going to
be making a bomb-making factory are they
going to be attacking you they're
plotting and planning or are these
people who are the most hospitable the
most kind and generous so we're going to
be educating you what do Muslims say
about the drawing of of the messengers
insulting the messages of God should
Muslims be reacting in this way or is
there the proper way that we're going to
be discussing here and the Deen show how
not to just be reactionaries how to go
about things the proper right way can
daddy show when we come back I'm going
please be with you sometime lake on
water you could set up a not a lawyer
what I care to it isn't it look when we
say peace be with you isn't it sad why
we that there's no harm coming you from
from me and no harm from you to me right
isn't it this is like expound on this
it's beautiful anything about it
agree with the names of Allah span or
Ta'ala as-salaam God Almighty ah yes
meaning the translation is the source of
peace why Allah is the force of peace
because whatever occurs and happens does
not change a lot panel that does not
affect Allah you see us we are in a
rollercoaster
one day were down when they were up
because we get affected by what happens
around us but allah subhanaw taala
nothing affects him that is why he is
the source of peace so when I say that
peace P upon you meaning made a source
of peace as salam alaihi salam bestow
his peace upon you so that you have
inner peace from Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
when I say also peace be upon you I am
Telling You that you know you can only
expect from me peace
I am not going to harm you whether in
front of you or whether in your back
and this is actually another way to
define who a Muslim is the Prophet peace
be upon him when he defined a Muslim
beside performing the five pillars of
Islam he said a Muslim movements element
Muslim ornament listen he worthy the
true Muslim is the one whom the rest of
people the rest of the Muslims are safe
from his tongue and his hand and this is
the message of Islam this is what Islam
is all about so he's so someone hears
this now but they go ahead and they see
in the media they see that okay as soon
as you say something against their
religion they come in with a k' and you
know we had recent events not too long
ago where you had the the newspaper
place to had drew the cartoon Dudley
Abdul yes everybody in there it was a
Muslim also who died a cop yes yeah so
now I mean how do you balance this now
obviously we don't like it's somebody
insulting Jesus Moses any of the
prophets but now is there a proper way
because people hear us talking about
peace but now you know you go ahead and
just bomb you see when there's some
people that we're talking about two
issues here and they should be addressed
separately or individually the first
issue is the rights of the messengers
and the prophets upon us imagine any a
lot of Hanna and Allah is the one who
chose these individuals to convey his
message and there is a beautiful piece
in a verse in surah al-anam Allah who
are a llama hydrogen or a Selita Allah
knows best who is entitled to deliver
his message a lobbyist of him in America
erosion and warming and ask Allah
subhana Allah is the one who chooses
from amongst the Angels Jibril
alehissalaam
and from amongst mankind the messengers
and he told us he commanded us to grant
these messengers peace look at the
version so latinum
Khalil hamdulillah say praise all praise
belongs to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala was
hell
the hill Edina Stouffer and those whom
allah subhanho wa taala chosen to convey
his message should receive peace from
you and the last version sort of the
soffit subhana rabbika ability am i a
cellphone
glorified and exalted the Lord of glory
above what they attribute to him of a
son saying that Allah if you look at the
context of these verses that they are
saying Allah he gets a son the Arabs the
motion because of the Arabs or the
Christians they say about Jesus and the
Jews when they say or say Israel and so
forth but look II was was a little more
saline peace be upon the messengers
that's why we as Muslims whenever any of
the names its s not just Muhammad
sallallaahu selling any of the names of
the messengers that will include Jesus
Moses David Solomon know anything when
they are mentioned we say sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam or alayhi salam peace
be upon that individual to show our love
to show our respect for these
individuals whom allah subhana wa ta'ala
chose to convey his message this is our
attitude as muslims towards any of the
messengers this is why when any of these
messengers and again i stressed not just
muhammad sallallahu wasallam any of them
is harmed by any newspaper by any deaths
we see how we feel we feel sad
we're upset because we love them dearly
we love them more than we love ourselves
we love them more than we love our
children we love them more than we love
our our family members our our wills
that is why we get hurt so non-muslims
need to understand this if non-muslims
realized yeah you know mohammed salah
salem is dearer to me than me where
would i be of mohammed salah salem did
not come to this world to show me the
way we're gonna take a break now you
hear muslim scholar is saying that not
only do the Muslims love Muhammad but
you mention Jesus in their Moses and all
the messengers we have
learn or Ferriero Vanina had a
university we do not place any
distinction amongst these messengers now
the proper course of action one only
gets insulted what should we be doing to
defend them back here in the D show in a
minute Selam says love all mankind
that's why we're sharing this message
because we want the best for you and we
want the best for all mankind please
subscribe to the Biggio follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show now Jesus gets
offended Muhammad peace be upon him you
have ignorant people out there and the
essence of free speech it's like you
know you you it's more of a free freedom
to insult right so obviously this hurts
our hearts when any of the messengers
are insulted but what's the right course
of action that a Muslim should take any
situation in the previous segment we
addressed the non-muslims we let them
know that there isn't why that rage you
know the reason why we're upset
but let me now try to get the attention
of Muslims in order to fashion or refine
is that a proper English refine our
response let me just begin by saying you
know how their religious literature
speak of Christian and Jewish meaning
I'm talking about the Old Testament and
the New Testament speak about the
prophets we understand as Muslims that
human hands gotten into these books that
means that they are not in their
original form they are destroyed it you
need for example the story of Prophet no
Holly salad was a beautiful story
someone who spent his life in the Quran
Allah tells us 950 years no one no no
one I saw that was Sarah spending nine
hundred and fifty years calling people
to Islam and that the numbers that the
highest number that we can put our hands
on and
so unless 70-something accepted his
message his story is almost identical in
the old testament but he find that
addition towards the end that after he
got off the ship he got drunk and he
committed what is known to be incest I
think that's he slept with his daughters
this is the religious text in the Bible
likewise profit lewd someone actually
who came to combat immorality the same
thing happened look that would aliens
urato asaram sent his general because he
fallen in love with what they would be
the wife of the general in order to get
him killed in a losing battle
so brothers sisters dear sisters dear
brothers that's the mindset of the
people here now us overreacting is not
helping the situation we understand that
we should not tolerate we should not you
know say it's ok we should deny this at
least with our hearts but we should use
the lawful legal means to combat this to
respond to this certainly killing and
shooting the way it happened in France
we condemn it there is no question about
it
you know this is turning it into a
jungle listen we do have a ruling in the
books of regarding those ones all the
messengers but if you have an
established judiciary system you have to
go through the process but this is Islam
doesn't condone this at all whatsoever
how should we respond you know Eddy
rasool allah jalla Suleiman and I really
love this and I'm telling them one of
the most beautiful things that that that
I you know I read in this context is
whenever salsalin took the journey of a
life you know he walked everybody you
know a lot of Muslims are aware of that
journey it's a heartbreaking experience
you know after the death of his uncle
harm started getting to him
and soon they'll be happy he said some
ascendant Quraysh was unable to lay a
hand on me but after the death of my
uncle so he decided to go to a path to
seek the help of the people there the
bottom line he was physically
emotionally abused imagine one of them
said a lot a lot a lot choose I'm sorry
I'm pointing at you but this is our
messenger was the Allah couldn't find
anyone better than you to send SMS you
you messenger clear insults yeah we call
the psychological abuse yeah you know
somebody said that I teared that the
curtains of the Kaaba if you're a
messenger and then he requests a safe
exit they did not even grant him this
you know they send the foolish and the
children to throw him water he was
pleading you know we have we have a
saying in Arabic says that when you see
your own blood vengeance becomes what
Salam walked out of this town and look
at the words that he used family -
that's actually a hadith in Bukhari
Muslim the hadith is authentic fail
Bihari he said I walked while I'm
feeling so much down and by all the
sudden I see the angel of the mountains
would accompany to gibreel what would
the angel of cinema and here is the
angel of the mountain giving rasulallah
saws and l'm the messenger of allah
sawas and i'm the opportunity to kill
everyone who abused him who emotionally
and physically abused them what did he
say what did he do then
you know what they said no he said no so
it's his time for revenge but he didn't
take revenge no you know what he said
you know the angel of the mountain said
- morini up to pathology Milosevic you
command me right Allah has given you the
authority to command me I will make this
mountains crumble over those people he
said no I just hope that their offspring
will say la ilaha illa Allah Muhammad
Rasul Allah
that's not what I'm not after the
destruction of people this is the manner
of Dawa
this is you know I want people to see
the truth I want people to see so much
and you know what Allah fulfilled his
wish look at this el valle de blue movie
Holly Merle et al ahzab Noah Ellis enemy
armor of the last abuja the fear of the
oma acraman
look at these names go go brothers go
sisters and check these names this
should be our attitude
it should be how we react because this
is the right way to go this is amazing
we're gonna take a break when he was
pelted and stone and spit on and
psychologically physically insulted the
last and final message of problem how me
peace be upon him what'd he do when he
was able to go back and have the angel
crush this city he said no he hoped that
they would one day worship the Creator
not the creation and it happened yes it
was fulfilled we right back with more
here on the Dean shoulder more anywhere
salam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind please subscribe to
the video follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the Dean show now we see
when we study the life of the problem
humming peace be upon him we see that
tolerance that mercy that compassion for
all of mankind that that dire a desire
that he wanted you know Allah is saying
in the Quran will you would you would
like kill yourself you know how to worry
and grief for who for everyone these
were non-muslims these are people who
were polytheists and he wanted the best
for him
now we don't kind of see that you know
when you when you're out there
communicating with people sharing it's
not our job obviously to convert anybody
but just to share this message right
when you're out there and you're
connecting with people you do you start
to have this empathy empathy and you and
you really want the best one but
sometimes you see some Muslims that now
this really harsh very intolerant
attitude and you know very violent some
what would you say you know again ITIL
the non-muslims please don't blame the
whole religion because of the behavior
of one or two one or two yes this is the
way it is it's very unfair and I tell
the Muslims come on let's raise it you
know any the description of the prophet
sallallaahu REO sadness was revealed in
the tower
and you know it's a beautiful author
that he should read after arm of the
light nom or the last all of your love
and woman but the prophets description
was revealed in the tower the wording is
dear and one of his attributes is ill
health
what is it health forbearance mmm-hmm
that somebody harm you and he is
deserving your punishment and you're
able to punish you're aware of their
horn and you do not need them and you
refrain from punishing them and rather
you treat them kindly this is what
helped the prophets allah salem during
his time there was a jewish rabbi his
name was a dog no similar he said i was
able to verify every single attribute of
the prophet mentioned in the tower
jewish rabbi the scholar was a scholar
they said i was able to verify except
this one that when you increase dealing
with him in an ignorant way his
forbearance increases so I decided to
test him in this area now he's gonna put
him to the test yes how did famosa
Burkle hacking for that those who wanna
go and review it so he went to the
mosque one day when an incident happened
in front of him that some Muslims needed
desperately some financial help
Rasul Allah Allah Selim asked Ali bin
Abi Talib rhodiola and whether we have
anything to give or not to give the
group of Muslims or not he said no they
don't know Ximena said this is my chance
so he went to the Prophet Solomon
Solomon said I will lend you the money
for one year of course no user ok so
after three months he came back
requesting his lawn and he actually
filmed the Prophet SAW from here from
his neck and he actually insulted him
and his tribe and this is a big no in
knock'em been wash empowerment look you
are the man wash in the tribe of Hashem
mutton
you don't pay back the he's really
putting to the test
oh yeah yeah Salem is like you know
standing on one of course was Dave I
know man wanted to interfere like he
would normally do
rasulallah Haris LM said to Omar was
Omar you should command him to request
his moon back in a better way and you
should encourage me to pay him back
maybe he's in need for the money maybe
look look at this they do blessed now by
the way maybe he needed the money when
he given it to us he was you know better
off but now it's just a matter of so
asked me to pay him back encouraged me
to pay him back now please take him and
give him his loan back and give him a
name
he wasn't like let's get him know
everybody jump now no give him an
increase you know this man said a shadow
la ilaha illallah wa ashhadu anna Karuma
he said there's nothing where they
worship except God Almighty Allah the
Creator this is a shot the last thing I
was waiting for to see your forbearance
yeah ayyuhan nabi look at the verses in
the tower
yeah ayyuhan nabi in our cell neck I
share hidden mobile sharing one idea
this is in the book of Isaiah Oh
Messenger we have sent you a bearer of
glad tidings and a Warner look at this
look at this hell's a little mean
security for the illiterate look Lester
be relieved in one of them well as
Harbin Phil as well you're not harsh
you're not tough and you don't speak
with noise you're not loud your yoga
layer zero can jello in la Elma when
people treat you ignorantly and increase
in abusing you because of their
ignorance that only increases you in
forbearance
we got to come on brothers will say
Allah Allah Muhammad Rasul Allah we
gotta act like Muhammad Rasulullah
we understand we don't like it we hate
it it makes us angry it makes us upset
there is no question about it but we
have to seek the proper channels to
combat this they have Facebook you have
social media spread this out there and
when we have an established judiciary
system then we can bring those people to
justice and the
ruling of insulting the messenger can be
done then but turning this into the
jungle will you go and take the matters
into your own hands
Islam doesn't condone this no question
about it
thank you very much shaker out of time
we started with peace we having a peace
and I'm like I'm taking so much stuff I
look at I hope you got to benefit from
this episode of the Deen show so
bringing proactive productive there are
things that now we don't like if Jesus
is insulted we don't like it Moses
Abraham any of the messengers of God
including the last and final message the
problem Hamid peace be upon him who was
sent as a mercy to the world and he was
the most forbearing now it's upon us to
go ahead and share because now how are
we gonna count combat this negative
propaganda is by us being vocal to
really represent Islam in the best way
with the best character and the best
mannerism so people can really
understand when they see the Muslims
they'll and then they hear the Fox News
and then they actually get to see Islam
in real life they'll say that this is
not nor does it have anything they will
be speaking out for us and not against
us we hope that you've gotten a benefit
subscribe if you haven't already and
we'll see you next week until then peace
be with you family